it's my great pleasure to
welcome you to this event and conference
at the victorian albert museum
also on behalf of yale university and
its president peter salovey
we have been talking about
organizing a conference like this on
illicit traffic and looting since the
last six
months pretty early on when i joined
yale university last april
martin and me got in touch and thought
that
would be really
a primary aim of the time
to bring experts and professionals
together to discuss this issue we little
could we know that
on april 14
we would be
doing this in an entirely different
context
and we thought about it a half a year
ago
i think for the yale university
which has been a university
since 1701
in new england
new haven connecticut
the first century maybe being a
university for
the american east coast and in the
second century
maybe a university for the whole country
but now
it has clearly global ambitions and
wants to be a global university
and
of course a university like yale with
global ambitions has to lend its voice
has to become an agora for discussions
like this discussions which are
clearly in need of a global and
international response
it's not so much about our voice but
it's really about your voice and i would
like to thank all the speakers and all
the participants who followed our
invitation as martin was saying to come
here to london to the victorian albert
museum
um i mean you are the essential voice in
this debate and to the same extent also
those colleagues who actually as martin
said send video presentations
powerpoints but who could not be here in
person because they are facing
completely different conditions of work
in their daily life in syria in mali
nigeria yemen libya and iraq
we have
together with
my colleague vernon rapley we have
structured the conference in different
sessions from lessons learned from the
past
current concerns on the ground
very important session about working
together perspectives actually in all
its diversity as vernon
loves to call it to embrace the
diversity of this debate i think is very
important as well
and of course ending with a roundtable
discussion chaired by hermann patzinger
from the prussian foundation of cultural
heritage about international
perspectives and the role
of museums
i think that cultural heritage
is about identity it's about knowledge
it's about
the future as well as it is about the
past
i think by coming here you make a strong
point to emphasize that at stake
at the moment is much more than just
artifacts and archaeological sites i'm
looking forward to a
interesting day of a lot of shared
knowledge
martin has said what we can maybe expect
as an outcome in the evening let's see
how far we get
but i'm very happy that you came and
thank you